>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington DC.
>> Stephen Winnick: Welcome
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Steve Winnick.
I'm the writer at the
American Folk Life Center.
And I'm here with Sheila Kay Adams
who is a fantastic ballad singer
and banjo player and
storyteller from North Carolina.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Thank you.
>> Stephen Winnick: And she's going
to tell us a little
bit about her life.
We're going to have an oral
history interview here.
So let's just start with you know,
general setting of the scene.
What is the Madison County and
Sodham Laurel Tradition like?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well when Cecil
Sharp came through 100 years ago,
he visited different people
in the Southern Appalachians
and somehow found his way to
this little community I grew
up in which is called Sodham.
The Laurel was added
later, I'm not sure by who.
But anyway, it was just
called Sodham back then.
And there were eight
traditional ballad singers
that were still singing
when I came along in 1953.
And I didn't start out really
seeking to learn the songs.
What I started out doing was
hanging out with the older people.
Because my real grandmother
died in February of 1958.
And right up the road from her
lived my relatively young --
although at that time I would
have thought she was ancient --
you know, she was probably
40, my great aunt.
And so when my grandmother
passed I went up the road
and adopted Dellie Chandler Norton.
And she turned out to be one of the
biggest influences on my whole life.
She was a wild crafter and
knew every plant in the woods,
medicinal value or not
so medicinal value.
She could point out
three little plants
in a small area five foot square
that would kill you if you ate part.
You know, so she knew her business.
But she was also a singer and
came from a family of singers.
The Chandler's have
always been singers.
Wallin's, they were always singers.
And the Ray's and the Norton's.
And she was from all those families.
And so the singing
was they just sang.
They sang all the time, literally.
You know, when they were in
the field working, they sang.
When they were up in the morning,
they were singing, washing dishes.
And before they'd go to bed they'd
all sit out on the porch and sing.
So that's what the
singing was kind of like.
And it didn't matter
what kind of song.
Anything from you know, Black is
the Color, a traditional ballad
from across the big
pond, to Carter Family.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
From sacred songs to,
"I see the moon, the moon sees me."
You know, anything that had
a tune, they could sing it.
>> Stephen Winnick: Well you
mentioned there briefly Cecil sharp
who came through, as you
say, just 100 years ago.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: And
recorded stuff in the community.
And you've mentioned before
a connection that you have
to one particular song
by Dearest Dear
that has to do with Cecil Sharp.
Tell us about that.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes.
Well, I had always heard
Granny and Berzil talk
about this English speaking
fellow, which I wondered about.
Because we spoke English
too, you know.
But I didn't realize mountain
English was different from English.
But as I got older, they told me
that this man came from England
to collect their songs because
he felt they were special.
And he put them in this big book.
And so that went along and I
went off to -- I went off, right.
I went to Mars Hill College
which is in Madison County.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
And in the library,
in the little index file
box, I found Sharp, Cecil.
You know, Folk Songs from
the Southern Appalachians.
And I got the book, looked at it
and it was both volume one and two.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And there was
my great, great aunt, Mary Sands,
who would have been a Wallin,
recorded by Cecil Sharp
on August 5th, 1916.
And my great, great aunt had sung
a song called My Dearest Dear.
And right over the ridge, her niece,
the next morning, gave
birth to my mother.
So she was in labor while my great,
great aunt Mary Sands was singing
for Sharp My Dearest Dear.
>> Stephen Winnick: And
now you sing that song?
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Oh yeah, absolutely.
And that's my mama's song, you know.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
Well tell us about Dellie.
So you said you adopted her
as your grandmother basically.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I did.
And she used to laugh and
tell people, "She adopted me
and I didn't have no choice.
Its little brain is
pretty determined
when she takes a mind,
has it that way."
And so I just -- but you know,
I think they appreciated
it, the older people did.
Because I was so interested
in everything they were doing.
But Granny was -- gosh.
She was I think ahead of her
time because she was born
in 1898, October the 3rd.
And the man that she was in love
with went off to World War I
and wound up -- he
made it back home,
but he died of the
flu epidemic in 1918.
Right, 1918.
And so she said that she
was an old maid at 21.
Barely turned 21 when my great
Uncle Ross asked her to marry him.
And he had four children of his
own, and then she had five of hers.
And she raised all nine of them.
And then he died in the '60's
and she was basically free
from that point forward.
And I asked her one time,
"Why didn't you marry again?"
She said, "Because I went
from being my daddy's daughter
to being my sister's handmaiden."
That would have been
Berzil when she married Lee.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
"To being my own person.
And there wasn't no man
going to tell me what to do.
Absolutely not.
After Ross died, I was done."
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
And what were her favorite
kinds of songs to sing?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Granny
loved all manners of songs.
She loved the Carter
family and she used
to sing Flowers After -- let's see.
Don't Give Me Flowers after I Die.
>> Stephen Winnick: Okay.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
After the Soul is Gone.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: That
was one of her favorites.
And then she would drag out
a love song or an old ballad
that was hundreds of
years old and sing it.
And she loved Herman's Hermit.
>> Stephen Winnick: That's great.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Yes, we used to dance
on the porch to Herman's Hermit.
There's a kind of hush.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: So she
loved all kind of music.
>> Stephen Winnick: Great.
Well you also mentioned
Berzil Wallin.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Berzil, yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick:
What were her big songs?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well now,
Granny had Little Farmer Boy
that she was kind of -- you know,
she considered that her song.
But now Berzil had one at almost the
same story, a little bit different.
But she called it House Carpenter.
Now they were sisters.
But Berzil's brother-in-law,
Chaz Wallin,
had one called The Demon Lover.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
they're all three the same song.
But Berzil had a way of singing
that was almost like conversation.
You know, The Girl I Left Behind Me.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Boy, she
could sing that and just --
but she had a great line.
And Johnny Dole, that was
one of her favorite ones.
She called it Johnny Doll.
And she said, "My ear bobs, they
buzz deep and fell to the floor."
And I always thought, "Golly,
what could call your ear bobs
to bust and fall to the floor?"
And Berzil was good at -- Daddy
said when they were young,
that Berzil was the one
that had such a sweet voice.
And she was the oldest one.
She lived up into her nineties.
I think she was like 97,
almost 98 when she died.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
You know, I remember seeing
her in the John Cohen film.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Right.
>> Stephen Winnick: Where she sings.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: She
looks ancient, doesn't she?
>> Stephen Winnick: She looked
ancient and she sang with depth.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: She did.
It's going to get you.
>> Stephen Winnick: It's
very, very spooky, yep.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
So I have kind of a weirdly
specific question about that film.
Because I understand you were
there when The Dance was filmed.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I was.
>> Stephen Winnick: As a child.
So there's one thing that
I noticed in that film,
which is Doral Chandler is --
there's a scene where he's
in a diner with a couple
of his male friends and
they're just sitting around.
And then later at the dance
one of those guys is there,
but he's wearing women's clothing.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Right.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Was that a tradition?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: No.
>> Stephen Winnick:
What was that about?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It was a dare.
>> Stephen Winnick:
It was a dare, I see.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It was a dare.
They dared Doral.
His name was Doral Chandler.
He was a nephew of
Granny's and Berzil's.
He was the son of their brother
Lloyd who first sang A Conversation
with Death actually, for
John Cohen I believe.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so
Doral, they dared him to do that.
And you just can't dare a
mountain man to do anything.
You know, they'll step
right up to the plate.
And so he showed up
and danced a little bit
with Peter Gaud if I remember.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
>> Stephen Winnick: He
was brave to do that.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well, you know,
a lot of mountain men are not too
concerned about their masculinity.
You know, they don't
have any doubt about it.
So I don't think it
bothered Doral at all.
It might have been a little much
on him when the camera was rolling.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
But he still did it.
Yep. We were proud of him.
>> Stephen Winnick: That
was interesting, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: So it's
funny because you know,
the way John Cohen makes his films,
he doesn't comment on anything.
So it's just there but
nobody knows what it's about.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
Doral appears and it's
very obvious he's a man.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Big
hairy legs you know sticking
out from under a dress.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And if I
remember, he had on a head scarf.
>> Stephen Winnick: I think
so, yeah, that's right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah,
but that also brings
up Dillard Chandler himself
who would have been another
influence and great singer.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah, he was.
He was a fabulous singer.
And Dillard I think was being
of my parents' generation.
He would have had -- he was the
one that literally had one foot
in one world and one
foot in another.
Because he talks about it.
You know, he says, "If I
have to make a little money
or make a living, I have
to go off from home."
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Because there's
no money here except in farming.
And the land's wore out.
That's what he said.
And so he would go into Ashville and
do landscaping for them rich folks
up there as he called it.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But yet he
would come back home, you know,
and participate in
whatever was going on there
around home, and still sing.
And he had a fabulous voice, I
thought, for singing ballads.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah,
that Soldier Travelling
from the North, the
way he does that.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Wow.
And he had another one that
was A Sailor Being Tired.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Yeah, great singing.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Yeah, fabulous singing.
>> Stephen Winnick: So you're
a girl and you're in this film
because the whole film crew
and John Cohen himself --
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And the
one person on the film crew.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah, that comes
and is filming your
family and filming Dillard.
Did that make an impression
on you at that age?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It
did, but at the same time --
see I've heard all the
stories about Sharp coming.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You
know, and being in that area.
So he was not surprised -- and
Allan Lomax actually had come
through there briefly in the
'60's if I'm not mistaken.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right,
I think that's right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: He came
through Ashville and wandered
over into Madison County a bit.
But anyhow, so yeah, it did.
It really influenced.
I forgot what the question was.
I'm sorry.
>> Stephen Winnick: Whether
it made an impression on you.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes.
Yeah, and what it did was
give me a boot in the backside
to get busy and learn these songs.
Because people from outside
thought they were important.
Yeah. And I mean, Granny
always said,
"There's a song for everything."
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
Yeah, that's great.
You know, one of the things that you
mentioned was Lomax coming through,
and coming through
Ashville specifically.
And that sort of sparked
in my mind the question
of Bascom Lamar Lunsford, and
what his influence would have been
on you.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well, Bascom
was an interesting character.
He was many things.
He was a lawyer.
He was a folklorist.
You know, a collector.
And he was also a bit of
a fancy dresser, you know.
He wore white suits and ties and
vests, you know, the whole thing.
And shiny shoes and the kids
thought he was kind of odd,
because he would get up on
stage and sing these old songs
without any accompaniment,
or just his banjo.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You know,
they'd have like a little
30-minute program of him singing.
And it was only later that I
understood how important Bascom was
to our area, because
he was Madison County.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
he actually went around all
over you know the western counties
of North Carolina and
collected songs.
And do you know, he
wrote Mountain Dew?
>> Stephen Winnick:
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: He did,
and he found himself in Chicago
without money to get home.
And he sold the song to somebody
for the fare back to North Carolina.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
That's great, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah, and
you know, it was also interesting
because he was one of the
people who had been recorded
in those early days of
recording in the '20's and '30's
and then was still around for
quite a long time after that.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: He was
definitely around in the '50's.
He was around in the '60's
because I took Granny and the crowd
up to the Ashville festival,
which I think is the longest-running
folk festival in the world.
>> Stephen Winnick: I
think that's true, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It didn't
even break during the wars.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
so I took them up there
and he would have people
come and sit on the stage
and then get up and perform.
And I can remember that.
And his son, Lunsford Jr.
was the agriculture teacher
at the high school I graduated from.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
So did Bascom encourage you?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: He did.
As a matter of fact, he gave
me -- if I remember right,
it was a nickel, because I
sang Little Margaret for him.
>> Stephen Winnick: So was that the
first time you got paid as a singer?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: So
I would have been third
or fourth grade maybe,
there somewhere abouts.
And he just came in and asked if any
of our family members sang
songs without like a piano.
Because he said if
you didn't clarify it,
then people would sing sacred songs.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: All day long.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But he asked
and I said, "Yeah, mine do."
And so I think that's --
I think he collected --
I know he did from Obray Ramsey
which was not Mama's
first sweetheart.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But yeah, that
was my first interaction with him,
was when he asked me if I
knew any of the old songs.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah, we
have several collections here
of Bascom's, one of which
he came here in I think 1959
and recorded his whole repertoire.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Wow.
>> Stephen Winnick:
But we also have one
which has some really good
footage of him with Obray Ramsey.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah, so --
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Obray
Ramsey I think is one
of the best banjo players
that's ever been.
>> Stephen Winnick: Well let's
talk about the banjo a little bit.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Okay.
>> Stephen Winnick: You know,
you're playing the banjo,
so how did you start in
that part of your tradition?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well,
you know, there was a lot
of family members that played music.
You know, and a lot of them
started out on the guitar
which Granny said didn't
even come into that part
of the world until about 1910.
And people just made up
ways to play it, she said,
because they didn't
know how to play it.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Which I think
would have been right after --
was it the Spanish-American War
with Cuba and we had some guys
that went down there and --
>> Stephen Winnick: That's one way
it could have come through, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so she said
that it was -- the guitar was --
I'm sorry, I've lost
the question again.
>> Stephen Winnick: Oh, I
was just asking how you got
into playing the banjo, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I was
when I was eight years old,
my cousin Jerry Adams said, "You
know, Sheila, I think it's time
that you learned how
to pick the banjo."
Because I had gotten
under Granny's --
well I got on Granny's bed after she
had drug it out from under the bed,
and put it up in the middle of
the quilt on her bed and said,
"Do not touch that banjo.
I'm going down to the
barn to gather eggs,
and so don't put your
hands on that banjo."
And when she came back,
I was playing Cripple Creek,
at least a type of it.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Did she say that to --
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Oh honey,
it was reverse psychology.
>> Stephen Winnick: To
make sure you picked it up?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Absolutely.
She knew. She said,
"Do not touch that,"
and I would be right
up on the bed with it.
Yep, a little reverse psychology.
>> Stephen Winnick: All
right, that was very smart.
That worked very well.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
>> Stephen Winnick: So you were
able to pick it up pretty quick.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I was.
And Jerry, I mean all he
basically did was show me the style
with what they call the pinch
picking or the two-finger style.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And then
when I heard Dwight Miller
when I was a teenager, then
I started playing clawhammer
and it's been on ever since.
I was about eight years
old when I started playing.
>> Stephen Winnick: So
did you learn from Dwight?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I did.
I learned tunes from him.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You know,
because I already could
play the banjo somewhat.
>> Stephen Winnick: Sure.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
all it took was just getting
that lick that Dwight does.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And he
said, "Oh, you'll get it.
Don't worry about it.
And then it will take a
year and half to get it
out to where you can stand it."
He was right, because it overpowers
everything at top, top sound does.
But yeah, I've been playing.
It is hard to believe.
At 64 now, I've been playing
since I was eight years old
and singing since I was five or six.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
That's a long time.
>> Stephen Winnick:
That is a long time.
Now how did you first sort of
realize that these songs were going
to be very important to your life?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Inez
Chandler passed away in 1981.
And she was really
special to my heart.
And she was hysterically funny.
She's one of the funniest people I
think I've ever known in my life.
And she called me out to the
hospital when she was dying.
And she said, "Now, I want
you to take care of things."
And I said, "What things?"
Now this was in '81.
You know, I was raising babies,
doing all that kind of thing.
And she said, "You make sure that
all these songs get sung, somehow."
And I said, "Well, I will."
And I was telling Granny about it.
And she said, "Well, Lord, yeah,
that's why we've been
learning them to you."
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so it
was in the early '80's I guess.
And my youngest son Andrew, he
loved to hear the story songs.
He wanted me at night instead
of telling him a bedtime story,
Andrew would say, "Sing one of
them old songs that tells a story."
Or he would say, "Tell one of them
stories about your Oldham times,
when you were a young girl."
And so that was where the book
came from, Come Go Home With Me.
>> Stephen Winnick: So your first
book was stories that you --
>> Sheila Kay Adams: A
collection of stories
that I told the kids
when they were little.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
Well you mentioned Inez
and there's another person
that you talk about a lot.
And that there's some
funny stories about her.
So what more can you
tell us about her?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Oh, there's
lots of funny stories about Inez.
She moved like a ship in full
sail everywhere she went,
with all this flowing brown and
dark green double-knit polyester.
And she would say, "You know, this
is the best material there ever was.
Because all you have to do is
wash it, hang it on the line
and you don't have to iron it."
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: She
says, "As a matter of fact,
it will melt if you iron it."
And she said, "It's what they
make them parachute cords out of,
and it won't break for nothing.
I mean, you can wear it forever and
it won't break, wear out, nothing."
Of course she said, "It ain't warm
in the wintertime, and it burns you
up in the summertime, but
you don't have to iron it."
You know, and she -- Inez
shared a lot of the stuff
that kids I think miss
about their people.
Because she didn't mind telling
me stories that were a little off.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You know,
kind of off on the other side.
You know, about who was
married to who really.
And her and Daddy both would say,
"You see them Hagins over there?
They weren't the Hagins's.
They were all Cooks."
And so you knew everybody's
legitimacy and illegitimacy,
walking through a graveyard
with them.
And she was also the one that said,
when Granny went in the hospital,
I guess she was in her late '80's.
I went down to see Inez after
that because she had called me
and by then we had phones.
She'd called me and said,
"If you go in to see Dellie,
then let me know how she's doing."
So I went down there
and she said, "Oh,
I already heard she's
doing all right.
She'll be home before
the end of the week."
And I said, "Well they had
her in intensive care."
And she said, "I know that.
They put everybody in intensive
care to see if they're going
to die or not, you know."
And I said, "Well God,
that's awful."
But Inez was that way, real blunt.
And she said, "And I hear
you said you was never going
to cut your hair again too."
I said, "Yeah."
She said, "Well she don't want you
to cut your hair again, right?"
And I said no.
She said, "Oh, you'll
cut that hair."
And I said, "No, I promised Granny
I would never cut my hair again."
She said, "Oh, you'll
cut that hair."
So back and forth.
And I finally said, "So are
you a fortune teller now?
You got your crystal ball
back in the bedroom there?
You're going to go look?"
She said no.
And I said, "So you can see
the future then somehow?"
No. "My past, honey, is your future.
That's what you've got
to look forward to."
And she said, "And you will cut that
hair when you get the mini-paws."
And at that age, I
thought, "Mini-paws?
Get the mini-paws?"
And I saw in my mind all
these little creatures coming
out of the woods, like
little rabbits
and raccoons with the mini-paws.
They're going to put
them on your body
and put little marks and mini-paws.
And then finally I said, "Are you
talking about the change of life?"
And she said, "No, I'm
talking about the mini-paws."
And I said, "And why exactly
would the mini-paws cause me
to cut my hair."
She said, "Because you'll get them
hot flashes and they'll just run all
over you like a dose of salt,
or like the Lord itself had laid
its hand right on top of your head.
And it will just run through you.
It starts right there and it
will just run all over you,
rips your head all
over, just wringing wet.
And you'll cut that hair."
And I said, "Well, we'll see."
And she said, "But you won't
have to worry about it, honey,
because you won't lose
no time working that hair
because you'll be too
busy working on your beard
and mustache after the mini-paws."
And I always said, well I told
my daughter the same thing.
And I said, "You know what's
awful is they're always right.
They were always right.
It never failed."
So working on your
beard and mustache.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
Well that was -- yeah, like
you said, you mentioned before
that she had sort of no filter.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: No filter
between her brain and mouth at all.
She would say whatever came to mind.
>> Stephen Winnick: And that
also made her your primary source
for dirtier songs, wasn't she?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
Dirtier, filthy.
>> Stephen Winnick: I was
shocked when I heard some
of the songs that she sang for you.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I know, I know.
That came out of my mouth.
And if you remember, I didn't
really want to do them, but I did,
because of Branson mainly,
you know, my fiddle player.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But boy, they
were -- a friend of mine said,
"There's a difference
in vulgar and raunchy.
And these are raunchy."
>> Stephen Winnick: Well I think
it's interesting for people to know
that that was actually
part of this tradition too.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: But it
didn't get collected very much
because you wouldn't sing those in
front of people you didn't know.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: That's right.
And you know, Cecil Sharp
collected a bunch of them
because Aunt Zip herself, who
lived to be 112, told me that,
"Well you know, I didn't just
sing four nights for him.
I sang all seven of them."
He left them out.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
The raunchy verses.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
the other thing was that,
I just think the raunchy songs
were taught a lot to the boys.
And when they finally got
a girl that was interested,
Granny and Berzil knew too.
They just didn't say much.
Boy, Inez, it didn't
bother her a bit.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
Well that sort of brings up
another part of the tradition
that you mentioned briefly that's
also big, which is the sacred songs.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: So you sung
those as a kid as well, didn't you?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Oh yeah.
And you know, we had every flavor
of Baptist style that
you could imagine.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Hard shell
Baptist, free will Baptist,
missionary Baptist, regular
Baptist, plain old Baptist.
Born in the shadow of
the cross, again Baptist.
Primitive Baptist,
progressive primitive Baptist,
foot washing Baptist, holy rolling
Baptist and buzzard Baptist.
And the buzzard Baptists were
those how only went to church
when there was a funeral, so that's
why we called them buzzard Baptists.
But Daddy used to say the Baptist
churches were about to swarm there
around home like a beehive.
Go down the road before they'd
cut down three and build
yet another Baptist church.
So we had plenty of
Baptist churches.
And I can remember as a girl
going from one Baptist church
to another and sitting outside.
You know, because if you were
missionary Baptist, you couldn't go
to no hard shell Baptist.
That might lead you
down the road, you know,
where you didn't want to go.
But I would sit on the bank
and listen to them sing.
And regular Baptists were
kind of boring I thought
because they all sung
in this same --
there was no harmony because that
was ornamentation to the song.
But boy, some of the rest of those
Baptists -- southern Baptists,
the harmony was just spot on.
And then they'd have the
shape note singings, yeah.
Sacred songs was a big part of it.
And I think one influenced
the other, Steve.
And I've not figured
out how it went.
If the balanced singing, kind
of those pauses in size and all,
influenced the scene
of the sacred songs,
or if it was the other way around:
the sacred songs influenced
what was being sung about.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right,
and it could have been both
and you'd never be able
to really pry it apart.
You did learn to sing
harmony, didn't you?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I did.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Singing school, right?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: With Chaz.
He would do a couple of
weeks in the summertime.
And he would have what
he called singing school.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
everybody had a shape note book.
And we did the Christian
harmony, you know, which is based
on the seven shapes as opposed
to the four like the sacred art.
And he would teach us the
shapes because you know,
soul, round, like the sun.
Do, you know, looks like you sat
down on something pointed
and made it flat.
No little trapezoid.
And "Do."
>> Stephen Winnick:
That's a good one.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Mi, you know.
Mi loves diamonds.
And so that's how he
taught all of us.
>> Stephen Winnick: Interesting.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Yeah, it was really cool.
So yeah, we did just about a
little bit of every kind of music.
The Carter Family, oh everybody
loved the Carter Family.
And Jimmy Rogers.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And
they listened to the radio.
I mean, it wasn't that isolated.
Except you know, in the 30's
we didn't have any except
for Irving Ramsey.
And Irving Ramsey had
dental work done.
>> Stephen Winnick: Gotcha.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And the
radio waves were conducting
through his dental work and they
would prop his mouth open, Steve,
put him on the store
porch in a chair.
>> Stephen Winnick: Really?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes, with ice
cream sticks to prop his mouth open,
and listen to John Brinkley
down in Del Rio, you know,
south of the border, live, 7:00
at night on Saturday nights.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Right, the Mexican radio.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: That's right.
Biggest one ever in the
northern hemisphere.
And the Carter Family would sing.
>> Stephen Winnick: That's right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
On the sunny side.
>> Stephen Winnick: Amazing.
So yeah, so now we've talked
about some of the songs,
but you also have a
career as a storyteller,
and that's another
interesting part of what you do.
So how did that begin?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You know, I'm
not really sure how that began,
because I had been
touring and doing music
since the early '90's full time,
you know, because I taught school
of 18 years in the
public school system.
And then I went out on
the road playing music.
And in 1997 I got invited
to Jonesburough
which is the big international
storytelling festival that goes
on the first week in October.
And if you ain't been, you ought to.
Because you'd love it.
It's fabulous.
And thousands and thousands
of people go now.
But see, I always looked
at it as just conversation.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Because
my daddy and his brothers --
I think I've told you, daddy's
mother and father had 13 children,
all of them boys except for
two twin girls born right
in the middle of them.
But you want to talk about a job
that I would not apply for,
but that's one of them.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And they
just kind of roamed about
and did what they wanted
to, but they would sit
at the family reunion
and get started talking.
And it was like this brother, Uncle
Nolan, would have one version.
Daddy would have another
version, and Uncle Wayne
and Uncle Garlan would chime in
and Uncle Andy would say something.
And it was phenomenal to
listen to them talk about.
But I got some great stories.
My daddy and Uncle Wayne went out
and gathered up two tow sacks full
of possums one night, alive.
And brought them back and right
before daylight they opened --
because nobody in Sodham
kept their doors locked.
They opened Granny Bear's door and
just threw both open bags of possums
into her cabin and closed the door.
And she said, "I'm going
to tell your mommy on you,
because I have gathered
possums out of every crook
and cranny of this whole cabin.
And I am wore slap out."
And that was two days later.
So Daddy said there must have been
150 possums in those two bags.
So they were natural
born storytellers.
And if they couldn't find one
to tell, they'd just create one.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
Well, it's interesting, because
you know, when I was young,
if you heard the term storyteller
and when there was a
storytelling festival,
it was mostly people telling
old traditional folktales.
And nowadays it's much more common
for this kind of family story
to be the story that gets told.
So I guess that's part of how
your stories would become part
of this scene.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Right.
Because unlike Ray Hicks and Rose
and Stanley Hicks and that crowd
down around Beach Mountain, my
family did not tell jack tales
or the grandfather tales.
Granny had one story she told
about Big and Little Nippy,
which would have been Big
Jack, Little Jack, same story.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But they
were more into singing the songs
and playing music and
frolicking and dancing.
And so they were not
those kind of stories.
But they had all these family
stories that they passed down,
and some of them will
just curl your eyebrows
at the stuff those people did
back in the 1800's and 1700's.
>> Stephen Winnick: Well
yeah, as a homeowner,
the thought of someone throwing two
large bags of possums into my house,
you know, that would
be unusual these days.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Right.
And the fact that she
was named Granny Bear.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: See,
now therein is another story.
>> Stephen Winnick: That's right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Her husband had
killed a sal bear as they called it.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
And was skinning it out
and there was a bear cub
crying out in the weeds.
Went and got it, took it home to
Granny Bear, whose name was Martha.
And she had just had a baby.
And she nursed that bear cub right
alongside that baby like twins
and it followed her around
like a durn big dog, you know.
Everywhere she went,
that bear was with her.
And it got to be a rather big bear.
And the circus came through and
her husband sold it to the circus.
She said, "It's just like
losing one of my young'ins."
And poor old thing, I guess it was.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah,
but it would be hard
to keep supporting a full
grown bear I suppose.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
And it's still a bear.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah,
it's still a bear, exactly.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: That's how
she got her name, Granny Bear.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
Well one thing that we're
very happy to have here
at the American Folk Life
Center is the collection
of the national storytelling
festival.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Absolutely.
I thought that was a
fabulous move on both parties.
Yeah, that was great.
>> Stephen Winnick:
So your performances
from that festival will be
here in the library as well.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep,
and I'm going back this year.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
So there's one festival performance
that was sort of big in your life.
And because I asked
about storytelling,
we kind of jumped over it.
So let's jump back to the
Smithsonian Folk Life Festival
when you first went there.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah,
that would have been the
bicentennial celebration of 1976.
And I would have been
23 at that time.
And you know how you are at 23.
You're just fresh out of
college and you know everything.
I mean, gosh, you learned
everything.
There's nothing else
that's going to --
I mean, when we went
to Washington that year
for the bicentennial
celebration for the Smithsonian,
I don't think I've
ever worked as hard
for so little money
in my entire life.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Because
they worked me to death.
It was something all the
time, but it was good stuff.
>> Stephen Winnick: So you
came up with your whole family?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I did.
I came up with them as a
singer, as one of the singers.
And it was really weird
because you had Evan Ramsey
who was probably 20,
30, maybe even 40.
Not quite 40 years older
than me, and then me.
So people would come up
at the festival and ask
if I was a volunteer, knew
where the first aid tent was.
Uh-uh. No.
Gosh, I don't know.
"Oh my God, she's one of
them," and would point
at the old gals over here.
And Chaz was -- I just left
him up to Bobby McMillan.
You know, Bobby was up
here at that time too
and started hanging out with us.
They got to know my family and they
adored Bobby and he adored them.
And so it was just a real
interesting festival to be --
and that was like I said,
one of the first big events
that we'd ever gone anywhere
together with each other.
But I drove the Station Wagon
from Ashville to Raleigh,
and then we flew on
the plane from Raleigh
after they had to take a gun.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Snub-nosed .38 from Granny,
all six chambers loaded
and ready to go.
They had to take it away from her
down at the airport
in Raleigh-Durham.
Because you know, it
wasn't as bad as it is now,
but you could still get on a plane
in Raleigh and wind up in Libya.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so, yeah,
it took me 30 minutes to convince --
I didn't think she could
find Libya on the globe
if her literal life depended on it.
And so they finally
said, "Well, all right."
And she said, "What about my gun?"
They sent it up to the pilot,
which gives me great you know
comfort now to think of that.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But yeah,
they sent it up with the pilots
in two separate sandwich bags.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
So the ammunition came
out, I take it.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And they
took the bullets from her.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Which she complained
about the rest of her life.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
Also they never gave
those back, just the gun.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Nope, just the gun.
>> Stephen Winnick: That was
probably sensible though.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: I would say
in DC, probably really sensible.
There's no telling what
she'd have done up there.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But it
was a very -- they had a ball.
You know, it was one
of the few times --
the only time I guess that most
of them had been here
to the nation's capital.
>> Stephen Winnick: Sure.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And you know,
me being the great world traveler,
having flown from home to
Philadelphia once one way,
but at the same time we were
housed at Georgetown University
and Barzil got lost down in
the works as she called it,
trying to find the bathroom.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Which was
four doors down on the right
on the hall we were staying at.
But she had been downstairs in like
the furnace room in the basement,
wandering around looking for
a bathroom for two hours.
And she said, "Well
I just feel foolish.
You showed us where
that bathroom was
and I've been down in the works."
And immediately red flag, red flag.
"Uh, what works?"
And she said, "You know, down there
where they keep the
suitcases and stuff."
And I said, "Suitcases?"
"Well you have to go
down all these steps."
And I said to myself, "Okay, an
86-year-old woman is wandering
around down in the works
while you are out singing
and raising cane with
Bobby McMillan?"
And then as soon as
I get back, you know,
the knocks started on the door.
They got up at 4:00, 4:30
in the morning every day.
I remember Granny saying,
"Yep, time to get up.
Gosh it's quarter to 5:00.
Half a day is done gone."
That would be 5:00 AM.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But that
festival was a real eye opener I
think for me because I don't
think I've ever laughed
as much in my entire life.
Because these were grown-up people.
And they did exactly what they
wanted to and did not care
who heard them, saw them.
They didn't even notice all these
other people wandering around.
They'd just get cussed
out and everything else,
walking down the sidewalks.
People would gather around you.
Or one of them would
just bust into song.
I remember Evelyn Ramsey singing --
ooh, it gives me cold
chills right now --
Black is the Color of
my True Love's Hair,
standing on some corner
you know in Georgetown.
She just got happy, wanted to sing.
And sung Black is the Color.
And she must have had 300 people
around her standing
there on that corner.
>> Stephen Winnick: Sure.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
>> Stephen Winnick: At the
festival, like you said,
you had seen the whole
mall full of people.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Oh yeah,
and they would follow us
around after Inez did her little do.
You know, she told dirty
jokes from the big stage.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so I
thought, "Nobody will ever come
to your concert or
see us ever again."
>> Stephen Winnick: She
knew what she was doing.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It was packed.
Everywhere we went there
was standing room only
and they were having to roll the
tents all up and do all that stuff,
because -- well I think, yeah,
she probably did know
what she was doing.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
Well it's interesting because
you know, you were joking
that she had no filter at all.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
>> Stephen Winnick: But then you
told the story and sang the song
that she did at the festival.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Right.
>> Stephen Winnick: And
although it's a tease song,
it wasn't really a dirty song given
the songs that she could have sung.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: She said,
"You know what, it's only dirty
in somebody else's mind."
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Wherever
their mind takes them.
I ain't got no charge over that.
But you're right, she didn't
sing Crawling and Creeping,
and she didn't sing Sweet Betsy,
and she didn't sing a bunch of those
that she could have
sung, thankfully.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
Yeah, so I mean in a
way she had a filter.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: There
was a wee bit of a filter.
>> Stephen Winnick: As I said,
she knew what she was doing.
Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And you
know, when she was talking to me
in the hospital and she
said, "You see about things.
Take care of things,"
she said, "I didn't mean
to embarrass you up there.
I hope I didn't."
And I said, "Up where?"
And she said, "Up yonder
in Washington."
And I said, "Honey, you
didn't embarrass me."
And she said, "Well
damn, I meant to.
I really did mean to."
And she said, "You just
needed straightening out
and reminding where you came from.
Don't you get above your raising.
Don't ever get above your raising.
You're fine just like you are."
And that was one of the things that
they gave me, was a certain kind
of confidence, a strength.
And recognizing that strength.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Which
has gotten me through a lot.
>> Stephen Winnick: It's gotten
you through a lot and I mean,
first of all, a performance
career isn't easy.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: No.
>> Stephen Winnick: And
so it's gotten you that.
But other things as well.
I mean, let's talk a little
bit about your film work,
the consulting you
did for Song Catcher.
What was that like?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well
it was really interesting.
I got a phone call and I'm not
even sure what the exact date was,
but it was something like
-- I don't know -- '94, '95.
From this woman who said she was
a film director from New York.
And immediately I went to
attention and red flag, red flag.
And she said, "And my husband and
I, David Mansfield, we're thinking
about doing a film based loosely
on the life of Ollie Dane Campbell.
And would you be interested
in helping us
with the songs and the singers?"
Because Cecil Sharp
had a huge influence
on what eventually happened
concerning Ollie Dane Campbell.
And I said, "Well, let
me think about it."
And so I made some phone calls
because I seriously at that point
in the '90's took my
role in keeping this --
because you know, Granny had
just died in '93 and Chaz in '91.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
I mean it was just
like dominoes since Inez had died.
So at that point I was taking
it really serious about the love
and passion I have and that they
have and that my family has had
for a long time about these
songs that are ancient.
I mean, some of them are -- I know
one about Eleanor's Confessions --
and who was she married to?
Henry III or something
like that, wasn't it, or V?
>> Stephen Winnick:
I think it was early.
It might have been Henry II.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Henry II, that's right.
And then when the Normans
invaded the Saxons.
And so these songs go back forever.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And somebody
had carried them over here
in their heart and then passed them
down into Granny's and Berzil's
and Inez's heart and
they shared them with me.
And their main goal was to get
them into the next century.
And so it became you know,
obvious that I was going to have
to be prepared to do that too.
>> Stephen Winnick: And so
that influenced your sort
of decision on that film?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah, it did.
As a matter of fact, I don't mind
telling you, it was Wayne Martin
in North Carolina who
is now our wonderful,
fabulous head of the arts
council in North Carolina.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And he's done
so much good work down
there for the arts.
He said, "Well, you know, Sheila,
somebody's going to do it."
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: "And why
not make sure it's done right?"
They called me from Sundance,
Maggie and David did.
And Aiden Quinn.
They were all three at Sundance.
And they were going to fly me
out to Sundance because the music
in the film, Song Catcher,
was winning so many awards.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
And I couldn't go.
But it was all right, because
that's what I hoped would happen.
You know, the authenticity
of the songs and the music.
>> Stephen Winnick: And you
had some people in the film
who were traditional singers,
and others who weren't,
who you had to teach how to do it.
What was that like?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Emmy Rossum
was a child prodigy opera star.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
As a matter of fact,
she was the latest female character
cast for Phantom of the Opera.
Yeah. And so she was
very, very talented.
Beautiful young gal.
And boy, I didn't realize
at the time
that an opera singer
basically mimics the sounds.
They don't really learn
all those languages.
Right.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so what she
was catching was every inflection
that came from my accent.
And boy she would sing those
dadgum things back to me.
And it was almost like
listening to me sing.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And Jim my
husband then came back and said,
"I thought you didn't
sing in Song Catcher."
I said, "I didn't."
He said, "Well I just
heard you on the radio.
I heard you on NPR singing."
And I said, "Jim, that
was Emmy Rossum."
"No, it was not.
We've been married a long time.
And I think I would know when."
And I said, "Jim, it
was Emmy Rossum."
And it was.
And then there was Bobby
McMillan, sang with Hazel Dickens.
And one of the actors
sang Beth O Death.
And then there was Phil Jamison.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You know,
local history professor that danced
with the big long legs that looked
like that stick that you pack.
But gosh, he can dance.
And so there were regular actors
and then there were homegrown folks.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
And I'll mention just for the
people who might watch this video
that Bobby McMillan and Phil
Jamison are both scholars
of this tradition as well.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes, they are.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Phil mostly in dance.
That there's a certain crossover
between the performers
and scholars as well.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
And Hazel Dickens.
And Hazel, you know.
She sang a verse in it as well.
And Iris Demen was
in it if I remember.
>> Stephen Winnick: That's right.
I think you're right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep, and she
sang Chaz's version of Pretty Sarah.
Yep. And Josh Goforth, a
cousin of mine, played fiddle.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
For their soiree.
>> Stephen Winnick: So
you were able to sort
of put together an
authentic music for this film?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well
I worked close with David.
David Mansfield is a
genius when it comes to --
I mean, he can play every
instrument, write music,
you know, do all that stuff.
And he is a fabulous composer,
done a lot of soundtracks,
that kind of thing.
But he loved the music
in Song Catcher.
You know, he's a great fiddle
player and banjo player too.
And we've kept in touch.
I mean, I thought that David did
such a great job with the music
in that film that I
will forever be indebted
to Maggie and to David Mansfield.
>> Stephen Winnick: Well
you did a great job.
They're indebted to you.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Thank you.
And they really appreciated it
too and they made it obvious.
>> Stephen Winnick: That's great.
So the other thing that you've
been doing lately is writing books,
right?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes.
>> Stephen Winnick: So
tell us about your writing.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well,
like we talked about earlier,
the first book was a book of
storytelling, or just stories
that I had heard or been a
part of you know in my growing
up over there around home.
And then the second one
was based on a story --
and the short story
collection was published
by the University of
North Carolina press.
And my favorite Appalachian
writer, Lee Smith,
had a lot to do with that.
Lee has written several
books about mountain women.
And she wrote one called
fair and tender ladies
that is just the best one I've
ever read about a mountain woman.
And so she was very
influential with that.
And then I wrote a novel based
on a story that Daddy told me
about two cousins that
went off to the Civil War
and they left their womenfolk
and families behind them,
and what happened to the
women while they were gone.
It's pretty gruesome in the
mountains, southern Appalachians.
It really was.
Especially North Carolina.
Because western North Carolina
voted to stay in the union.
And the rest of the state
voted to leave the union.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And so it was
a little iffy there for a while
as to whether the mountains
would say
in the state of North
Carolina, yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: And both
books did you know fairly well.
I was really pleased
with how well they did.
The novel was first published
by Al Gonkwin of Chapel Hill,
and then it got picked
up by Random House.
So you know, it's paper back
so I thought, "Well shoot."
But I've got one more
book in me I think.
Actually I've got several.
I'm working on one now called
The Hanging of Peter Smith.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: So
you already know then,
Peter Smith's going to get hung.
But it's told from the perspective
of four women, different women
who tell different stories about
Peter Smith but they all lead
to the gallows, you know.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
And that's a true story.
Because Peter Smith was
the last man legally hung
in the state of North Carolina.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
But I've got one I want to write
about my family's take or you know,
the way they looked at
outsider folklorists coming in
and collecting their songs.
And how it went form Cecil Sharp
to -- gosh, who was the last.
I guess Alan Lomax is the last one
in the '80's, early '80's, '83.
>> Stephen Winnick: So was he
with a video crew at that time?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
And he had a crew of
more than one, yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: He had a
larger crew than John Cohen did.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: But I would
really love to write that story
about some of the things
that they said happened.
And some things I witnessed myself,
like Doral Chandler
dressing up like a woman.
That really happened.
And it was on a dare.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
I think it's funny because I think
a lot of people watched the film
and they don't actually notice that.
You know, it just kind
of goes over their heads.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Gosh, I don't know how.
Because you know, his
shoulders are this broad,
big hairy legs hanging down.
>> Stephen Winnick: I know, but
I've mentioned it to several people
and they've said, "I
don't remember that part."
So whatever.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
Well so in your community
now, in Madison County,
there's sort of a revival
of the ballads.
I mean, a lot of kids are
collecting them and singing them.
What part did you play in
that, and how is that going?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well it's
really interesting because when --
and you know, now that I think
about it, Song Catcher back
in the late '90's kind of you know
boosted some of my cousins along.
Donna Ray Norton, one of the best
ballad singers I've ever heard --
she's about 35 maybe now.
And she's absolutely
stunningly authentic.
My daughter is a great
singer, Melanie.
And it was kind of that Song
Catcher, just like John Cohen did
for me and Cecil Sharp did
for Granny and that crowd.
You know, kind of gave
them a little lift.
And then there were these kids
that started coming to me.
Elizabeth Laprel, who is I think
one of the best ballad singers
that ever stood upright and walked.
Sam Gleaves, same thing.
One of the best ones
I've ever heard.
And around home we've
got Ash Devine,
who is such a great ballad singer.
She's from southwestern Virginia.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Right
around where Doc Watson is from.
Sarah Lynch Thompson who is a
fabulous activist and ballad singer.
And Branson Raines, my
little fiddle player.
His voice has gotten -- it's just
cream of the crop now, you know.
So there's a bunch.
And my grandson Ezra
who will be 11 in May.
About a month ago he was spending
the night with me and I was talking
to him while he was you know
getting settled in his bed.
He said, "You know them
old songs we sing?"
and I said, "Yeah."
He said, "You know any about
people killing anybody?"
I didn't ask you know if he'd gotten
into like harming animals
or anything.
But he just said, "No, mama
put in one of your CD's
and I really liked one of them."
And I said, "Oh really?
Which one did you like?"
He said, "It's about a drunk man."
And I thought, "Okay,
Four Nights Drunk.
Here we go."
But he can sing Four Nights
Drunk and Jerusalem Morn.
But it's my granddaughter
who's coming along too.
She's missing her two
front teeth right now
and she's embarrassed
to sing right now.
But Carlie Rose can sing.
And with a name like that,
Carlie Rose, oh yeah.
She loves the old songs and loves
to -- she doesn't know the words.
She'll be seven this year.
But she doesn't know all the words,
but she'll make them
up, tell the same story.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: So a lot of
these singers that you're talking
about are relatives of yours.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Some of them not.
But another thing you've been doing
is going to places like Augusta
and teaching in a more
kind of almost academic way
where people come to you from all
over the country to learn ballads.
So how does that differ?
What is that like?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: If there's
a young person in that crowd,
I can guarantee you they'll be
at my house spending the
night within six months.
Because I'll bore in
on the young folks.
Because you know, that's
where it is.
That's what it's all about.
It's about handing -- well nobody
said it better than Cecil Sharp.
He said, "From birth we are
given this right to these songs.
They belong to us."
And so that's what
I tell these kids.
And boy, they come just
like shots, you know.
And they'll spend -- Sam spent a
whole summer at my house, you know.
And it's just wonderful.
Branson was there for two years.
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yeah, so
that's what it's all about.
It's about passing it
down, passing it on.
>> Stephen Winnick: All right,
that's a great sentiment to have.
We love to hear that because
we're involved on the other end
in collecting these things
and keeping the collections
for future generations.
And the fact that you're doing
the same thing just as a person,
you're an archive,
teaching it to them.
So that's wonderful.
One other thing I wanted
to mention is the fact
that you're the recipient of
a National Heritage Fellowship
from the National Endowment
for the Arts.
So tell us about what that was like.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Well, as you know, Steve,
my husband Jim committed
suicide in 2009 in March.
And I felt -- I didn't know if I was
going to make it through it or not.
But the funniest thing happened.
I started to remember these
songs that came from Granny.
Because she would say, "You know,
laugh or cry, honey, sing a song.
Laugh or cry, sing a song.
That's what's going
to make you better.
That's what's going to heal you."
And so it was like I just
forgot about the here and now
and I just leaned back, closed my
eyes and fell back into the arms
of all those loving women
with all those songs.
And Jeff Warner who's the son
of Frank and Ann Warner --
another great team of collector
all over North Carolina, you know.
>> Stephen Winnick: We've
got their collection to.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yes, you do.
And I'm going to look
at it tomorrow too.
He came to me and Jeff is such a
fine and nice and wonderful person.
And he said, "Sheila, I'm
so sorry to hear about Jim.
And I want to teach you a song."
And I thought to myself, "I do not
believe that he just said he wants
to teach me a song now, three
months after Jim's death."
And he said, "No, this
is one, Sheila,
I promise you've got
to learn this song."
And he taught it to me.
He sat down and I learned
it the old style.
He'd sing it, I'd sing
it back to him.
And that's how I learned it.
And it was Her Bright Smile Haunts
Me Still, that was collected
out on the outer banks
by his parents.
And isn't that amazing?
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It looped
around the world, you know.
Because that song that she sang
was the song that they sang
on New Year's Eve when the guy
went around and checked the gates
for all these little
pounds in Scotland.
>> Stephen Winnick: Okay.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: That
was the one that he sang
in this little place I
think called Iverness.
>> Stephen Winnick: Okay.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Or Iberness.
And so it went from
there to the outer banks
to -- is it New Hampshire?
>> Stephen Winnick: I think
it was New Hampshire, yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
To New Hampshire,
back to western North Carolina
and then I took it back to England
and sang it this past summer.
>> Stephen Winnick: Very nice.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Nice.
>> Stephen Winnick: So Her
Bright Smile Haunts Me Still.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
Only I changed the words to His
Bright Smile Haunts Me Still.
Yeah.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
So I mean, that experience
is sort of one
of the universal experiences I
think that people who perform
or who have traditional songs
in their background have.
Which is you know, these tragedies
happen to us and then we realize
that well, these tragedies
have happened before
to generations of people.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: For
thousands of years, that's right.
>> Stephen Winnick: And
here it is in the songs
that I already know and
that I already sing.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Yep.
And you know, that's a gift
to be given those songs.
And to be given that knowledge
that it ain't just you, honey.
And somehow they made it through.
>> Stephen Winnick:
Yeah, but then a couple
of years later, to
get that recognition.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: To get the
NEA award, that was in 2013.
And Jim died in 2009.
And so when Barrie Burgett got
ahold of me, you know to tell me
that I'd gotten it, I
thought he was calling me
to ask me to MC the event.
Because I thought maybe something
had happened to Nick, you know.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Nick
Spister who usually does it.
And he said, "No, no.
I want you to come up here
and get yours and take it back
to North Carolina with you."
And I just started bawling.
I was mowing the grass.
It's one of those I'll
always remember where I was
when I got the news from that.
And then I found out George Hold
had worked so hard and tirelessly
to get all the material and
all that stuff together.
He and Wayne Martin.
And I mean, getting
that award, Steve,
really lifted me out of that hole.
You know, and gave me the incentive.
Because when you get an award
for keeping alive something
that was given to you,
what are you going to do?
Go home and sit down?
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: No.
You're going to keep going and
working with these young people.
Because that's why
you were recognized.
And it saved my life.
It absolutely saved my
life, getting that award.
And I am so appreciative of the
National Endowment for the Arts.
It has done so much
for so many people.
Two of my family members
received that award.
Doug Lawler and me.
>> Stephen Winnick: That's right.
So we didn't talk about Doug at all.
We talked about Chaz.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Doug and I were cousins.
And for that to happen in one little
tiny community is pretty impressive.
And you know, to have gotten the
North Carolina Heritage award
in '16.
But it's not about the awards.
It's about getting the recognition
for having done something you love
and have a passion for,
and them saying, "Good job.
Good job."
You know. And that means a lot.
And I'll be forever grateful.
Because they saved my life.
The NEA saved my life.
>> Stephen Winnick: Well another
thing that that sort of prompted you
to do I think is do more
touring in the last few years.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Absolutely.
Well, let's put it this
way, it's enabled me.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
Sure.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: It
encouraged me and enabled me.
Because when they hear that National
Endowment for the Arts Fellowship,
you know, then they're
more interested
in having you come and do.
>> Stephen Winnick: Right.
So you've been pretty
much everywhere.
You've been to Australia.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Australia this time last year.
In August I was in
England for five weeks,
all over England doing
those big festivals and all.
And then I was in France, in
Paris and Normandy in December.
>> Stephen Winnick: So how does
it differ, taking these songs
to audiences from other
countries which aren't so local
and so aware of the tradition?
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Do you know
that in Australia I had people come
up after concerts crying and saying,
"I have not thought of that song
in 60 years, since my
grandmother sang it."
Because you know, we're
all the same.
I mean, all over the world.
It doesn't matter whether
we're English speaking.
It doesn't matter.
In France, you know, they
would come up, "Merci, merci."
Because if you have something
that you have spent a
lifetime -- you know, 64 years.
Let's face it, that's a lot of time.
That's six and a half
decades, right?
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: So if
you're that interested in it,
it must be worth something.
And if you can ever get people
to sit still long enough --
and there was one man who came
up and said, "Same versions,
same songs here, sung in French."
>> Stephen Winnick: Yeah,
there are some of those too.
Isn't that interesting?
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
Very interesting, yes.
[Inaudible] we have here.
>> Stephen Winnick: Very good.
Well I just want to thank you for
the concert and this interview
and all the things that you've
told us about your tradition.
We really appreciate having you here
and having this in our collections.
It's a treasure.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: Well it
has been my honor to be here.
And y'all do good work.
Keep it up.
Don't quit.
>> Stephen Winnick: We'll try.
>> Sheila Kay Adams:
All right, all right.
>> Stephen Winnick: Thank you.
>> Sheila Kay Adams: You're welcome.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.